let's say that you agree to lend me some
money say you're agreed to lend me 100
and i ask you all right do i just have
to pay you back 100 and you say no no
you want some interest and i say how
much interest and you say that you are
going to charge me five percent per
year
interest
so one way to think about it is if i
borrow 100
today
so 100
in a year i'm going to have to pay you
back 100
times i'm going to have to grow it by 5
so that's the same thing as multiplying
it by 1.05
this is how much i'm going to have to
pay back let me write this down this is
borrow
this is what i'm going to have to pay
back
and so this interest rate that just the
face value of how much more i'm going to
have to pay back this is known as the
nominal interest rate
nominal
interest
rate and we can compare this to the real
interest rate
and you might say why do we need some
other type of interest rate
well even though on the face value i'm
paying you back five percent more that
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to be able to buy five percent
more with the money that you get paid
back and you might guess why that is the
case because of inflation a hundred and
five dollars will not necessarily buy
you in a year what it might buy you
today and so that's what the real
interest rate is trying to get at
and to do that to calculate our real
interest rate we are going to have to
think about inflation so let me put
inflation right over here
and so let's say that we are in a world
that has two percent inflation
so an indicative basket of goods that
costs a hundred dollars today if this is
the inflation rate would cost a hundred
two dollars in a year so there's two
ways that folks will calculate the real
interest rate given the nominal interest
rate and the inflation rate
the first way is an approximation but
it's very simple and you can do it in
your head and that's why it's often the
first way that it's taught but it's not
exactly mathematically correct so the
first way you'd say well this could
approximately be equal to the nominal
interest rate minus the inflation rate
so you could say this could be
approximately equal to five percent
minus
two percent which would be equal to
three percent and this is a decent
approximation but the actual way that
you would want to calculate this if you
wanted to be more mathematically precise
is that your nominal interest rate
multiplies things by 1.05 so 1.05
but then things are getting more
expensive at a rate of 2 per year or
another way to think about it costs are
being multiplied by 1.02 every year so
we divide by that amount 1.2
every year and so this was going to give
us
1.05
divided by 1.02
is equal to 1.0294
1.0294 and or another way to think about
it we just got a much better sense of
what the real interest rate is it's
actually much closer 2.94
interest and this is a very small
difference and so that's why people like
this method you can do it in your head
and it got pretty close but keep in mind
even very small changes in interest can
make a big deal when we compound over
many years in other videos we've talked
about compounding